whether it's munich's oktoberfest or
cologne's carnival
beer plays a leading role in germany's
big celebrations
covert has hit those parties hard as the
need to
implement coronavirus measures has seen
them cancelled
and bars and restaurants closed which in
turn has had a knock-on effect for
brewers
really bad is the situation of the
smaller breweries because they
they are often selling their beers in
restaurants and pubs
and as you know pubs and restaurants are
closed
since november so there is no beer sales
at the moment
for them be a sales have actually been
declining in germany for a while now
understood to be due to health concerns
but over the last year
they have gone off a cliff 17.3
down on year-on-year sales for april
14.1 down for november
some have looked to diversify to move
with the times
when a court in bavaria overturned a
ruling banning the sale of alcohol in
public spaces last
month this brewery in munich set up a
beer
vending machine so we have here the
mobile tank which was created with two
other companies
and here you have fresh tank beer that
you can tap using the app
all you have to do is download the app
then top up your credit card and then if
you scan the qr code you can tap
directly through the app
and also pay contactless so that is also
entirely covet conforming
while a brewery near nuremberg saw a
rush on their lockdown creation
named vaccine the 2000 cans they
produced
selling out in just over three hours
cans and bottles are usually the
territory of the larger producers
the vast majority of germany's small
brewers sell direct to bars and
restaurants
all of which are closed with no real
indication
when they'll reopen the german
government has provided financial aid
and while it has helped
it isn't a solution over 300 brewers
have signed an open letter sent to
angela merkel's government
warning of an existential crisis in the
industry
while a lot of the talk has been about
getting schools
shops and hairdressers open there's no
end in sight to covert restrictions on
the hospitality industry
if i can't open i have to take on more
debt but i really need an opening date
i understand that it's difficult with
the situation as it is but if i don't
have an opening date i don't know
um how much money i will need until that
day and i constantly will need to keep
looking for more money somewhere and
this is just it's
just immense challenge and eventually it
will not work anymore
and eventually it also won't make any
sense this breweries use
the time that they've been closed during
the pandemic to upgrade
production facilities in order to allow
them to sell beer in cans
but that all comes with extra costs and
extra costs
come with extra risks just by government
support alone it's impossible to survive
this
so it's just more and more debt and
eventually it's already
almost impossible to get money from
banks because they're seeing the
situation as it is and why would they
give businesses that are basically
bankrupt
at this stage why would they give them
money so it's just private investors
that you rely on that you hope that they
will
believe in the business believe that
they can come back strong the hope is
that
scenes like these can be seen again by
the summer
but fears over mutated variants of
covert 19 spreading through
germany as many painting a less than
rosy image for the remainder of 2021
which will likely lead to a continuation
of restrictions in some form
all of which will take a serious toll on
germany's brewers
peter oliver rt berlin